[Music]
the tube station there 0.5 miles but not
just from that Tube Station
and that one was Tube Station was
everywhere hello hello hello hello hello
[Music]
hi Meg good to meet you this is Diego hi
hello Diego Diego
so he's the architect and he also does
the project managing um for the whole
project so right he's got me a lot of
planning in the past so good happy with
Diego well good to meet you Diego
so what's the what's the vision
so the vision is taking a standard house
and making it into a luxury home this
area is Queens Park
sought after a very family-oriented
Orange area
um so we're taking this very bog
standard looking house and making it a
wonderful family home
um that you can raise your children in
and you've got it on an auction so so
it's been secured option uh or better
yet a purchase was delayed completion of
six months because of the um interest
and everything that was going on in the
economy have you already completed on
that yeah so that's completed on it yeah
so you've got to buy it you've got to
buy it so I have to buy it in six months
oh that's exciting yeah well how much
are you buying it for so um it's been
secure for one million and fifteen
thousand check you out yeah yeah go back
you're doing this what happens when I
get trained by you guys the thing is
that you went to Huddersfield and you
started doing big deals in Huddersfield
yeah but now you do the same types of
deals now in London which is yeah crazy
you're buying it for just over a million
yeah and then how much do you think the
refurbished so at the moment we've got a
refurb at 200 000.
um but you know we're going to have a
look at some materials we're going back
and forth on the plans at the moment
what do you think the End by will be uh
I mean gosh conservatively very
conservatively 1.6 uh sorry yeah 1.6
probably 1.65 what do you think about
the market because it's obviously not
the it's not like a seller's market
right now yeah absolutely so yeah I mean
you know the thing is we are pushing up
the value
um of the property and I feel like even
if we were to sell it for 1.5 would
still walk away with the 200 000 pounds
what's the square uh meters or square
footage so at the moment it's
um
1450 and we're taking it to 1009
one thousand nine hundred yeah
okay so I can see what it would sell
we've just been doing a lot of
calculations seeing the street and about
so that that probably makes about sense
1.6 is so where are you adding space
then so it's got permissive development
rights obviously after learning from
yourself uh Russell we uh extensively
dig and I had a look at you know this
particular Road and you know its ability
to get planning and we discovered that
it has permitted development rights
um so we can do already in place already
we're submitting the drawings to
activate it so okay okay it didn't have
permitted development no it has
permitted development right it's got the
right
version right for a lot of conversion
and I think when was the uh late the
earliest
um planning that's gone through for loft
conversion for a lot of conversion as
well this uh been a um a couple of
schemes approved this year uh for a lot
of conversions in this road
um and this is all on the publicity
development because it's not going to
cost area yeah which means that you can
get away with um boxed Dormer or an
L-shaped Dormer uh fully without black
on the PD no applying required brilliant
brilliant oh nice job jail is just
amazing how many how many projects have
you worked on oh my God I mean we've
been working together for like 10 years
wow yeah so he's done commercials so he
got me for my club he got me
um this is your boy right this is my guy
this is like literally Diego's
everything so oh that's so good we chose
to randomly yeah sure I'm really excited
to see it yeah the idea that um Diego
we've got a few drawings is to have a
look at but we're looking to open it all
up and we're actually looking to extend
do a side extension
um to the rear of the building as well
so that we can create a nice open space
and we're just discussing what that's
going to be to lead us into the kitchen
are you buying it so you buy it as a buy
to let
so it's getting bought on a bridge
okay it's getting bought on a bridge
and it getting developed on a bridge
using bridging finance and you've been
accepted already for the finance I have
got a um a learning principle nice it's
a really nice project yeah thank you
it's a great area as well how did you
find it like what was the process I have
been looking at this for about three
months yeah and it was uh yeah it was
secured and then it fell out because the
interest rates went up and that's when I
was able to get a very hungry seller so
you're in negotiations with them and
then when interest rates went up
Suddenly sellers got super motivated and
that's why you managed to get so cheap
that's it because that's the thing right
be easy people to say oh but the end
value might be less because of the dip
but it's like yeah maybe it will but so
was the front at front value so was the
purchase price so you can't just be like
being negative about the end value
you've also got to be positive about the
front value and ultimately kind of
balance itself out a little bit and
we're in a position where obviously it's
being purchased and developed and we're
pushing that value up but also we have
got a couple of different uh strategy
exit strategies as well if for any
reason the market is not looking
favorable to hold and it currently has a
HMO license as well yeah for I think uh
five or six five or six people yeah yeah
okay so you could do it and it's not a
Conservation Area either yet but it will
be there's a plan to extend the
conservation area just south of us yeah
this in the future so this property will
be covered in the conservation area so
yeah bought the property I think at the
right time yeah just before he turns
into good Conservation area of course
learn from the best can't take credit no
that's really good okay cool right I
like it it's so big isn't it it's going
to be huge yeah it's going to be really
big
so it reminds me of sorry it reminds me
of um your it's got your stamp on it you
know what I'm saying it's something I'm
just so passionate about creating luxury
homes yeah you're Jail's got like a
certain stamp of house and it's always
big never small always big in
Huddersfield it'd be like a castle I
don't know if you saw any of the houses
did you see like like freaking huge man
like 10 bed 12 but you just got this jet
but nice it's like on a lease option as
well yeah on a lease option but also
like quality not like just big and ugly
like got a bit of character yeah you
know you go you've got a very good
um in intuition I think about property
oh so perfect obviously with the help of
Diego he gets he gets all the messages
like yeah it's fine so we're going to
open this up it's going to be extended
to the side we're going to add some um
light Wells
um to it as well to bring in some more
natural light this uh is definitely
either gonna go or we're discussing at
the moment if we are gonna create a new
one here's a question what will you do
if the bridging company say you can't
get bridging and you've got to buy it
because you've got it on a delayed sale
oh yeah no it's like the only thing that
I could probably think of at that point
is to package it and sell it
right and you've got an assignable thing
in the in the contract where you can
assign it to somebody so at the moment
that's what yeah so we have got um we've
got assignable and we've
been good yeah yeah only if there's an
actual a valid reason as to why and it's
been signed or everything's been signed
yeah
excited yeah you don't want to put the
assignable thing in there it just means
so for whatever reason you can't get the
bridging or whatever you've got that
exit strategy you've been able to I'm
sure that won't happen but it's just I
mean the the idea is to get it all
wrapped up way before the six months so
really in the next
um two months yeah everything needs to
be done what we what uh thing that I
learned from my last development is to
get the planning in place now
um because when we go on to the the
bridge we want to go into the bridge
when we know exactly what we're doing so
that we're on there for a limited time
now the contractor has said it could
take as little as six months you know
subject to you know obviously things
that may vary so but at the same time
we've got 12 months
um you know then we've got an extra six
months with the with the um the
agreement so yeah I feel like we've got
enough time so I'm actually moving down
the road from here
um which I'll be moving to in a couple
of hours sort of like absolutely yeah
100 so we're going to bring this out out
um and I think you'll be able to do that
going so close to there
door and windows and whatnot yes you do
yeah yeah so there are some so this
Council
um lets you do an internal extension
provide it it has certain Heights
um if you stick to those Heights uh I
think it's two meters on the bundle line
and there are a few houses that have had
extensions approved with the same same
so with ground floor extension only the
ground floor yeah two meters on the
boundary line in terms of height and
then it it slopes up and that's what
number one did okay which is so there's
a president as well yeah yeah we've
actually got a viewing booked out one uh
so 12 30 if you're around well oh so we
can all go in
um
just to check out the spec the what
they've done and see if there's anything
we can learn from it that might be worth
so we're just actually trying to figure
out whether we want a bigger Garden uh
we're basically wanting to find out what
the clients want a bigger Garden or more
space inside so so that might be it or
not just knock it down yeah absolutely
turn into a bit of a garden a lovely
Garden having a garden no like people
especially in London and as a family
people love a garden in London and that
is not good for anybody no one wants
that no it's this here that we're
contemplating whether to take off or
leave or create a new version of it um
because
um yeah we might create a bigger Garden
we've taken this away yeah or we might
actually add it to the house and yeah
see which one adds more value so again
really generous space
um we've already had a building survey
been carried out
um to see if there's any asbestos or
Japanese well not weed or any structural
issues the only thing that we did find
was um dry rot
um but we managed to negotiate it down
to 10 000 pounds because of it oh that's
great where there was no
um structural issues no structural
issues yeah wow if you can get this
refurb done including a lot of stuff for
200 Grand I think you've done really
well yeah but then jail is very good at
getting big refurbs done on a on a good
budget yeah no I we definitely I've seen
some of her work man it's just like
crazy literally full Reverb on a massive
house on such a budget because I think
eight thousand pounds or something yeah
I know because I think you complained
afterwards
before you know what though because
because like she was literally like
getting everybody herself like I'm
getting the electrician here a prominent
project managing the whole thing and
yeah you know we have a contractor who
are amazing and um you know very very
transparent and um and of course we'll
be working very closely with Diego to
make sure that all the uh necessary
sign-offs are done as as they go along
um which is very where did you get the
200 000 pounds from so contractors come
up with a figure but it's subject to the
decision we're going to make on the
drawings of course yeah so it could go
up it could go it could probably likely
to go up more than anything but
um I think there was enough 400 000 I
think it's quite a lot
um I'd be happy to walk away with 250
000 in profit
um so it gives a bit of room yeah
cool and how much money do you have to
put in like in terms of the bridge and
how much do you reckon you're going to
get from bridgen so it's all here
but all the money in at the moment all
the cash in is just shy of 500 000
pounds so it's 487 000 pounds that's all
cash in
um does that include stamp Duty yeah but
that might go up a little bit okay
um so that's the cash in and then the
lenders are going to be borrowing 766 so
there's a breakdown here of the net loan
um and then that's also the net um works
as well
um
so that's kind of what they'll give to
us and I've already agreed with the
contractors to give us the um to to to
to receive the funds when they release
the funds which is delayed so the
contracts of even willing to put the
money up front oh wow for the projects
yeah which is great that's pretty
impressive yeah what what made you
decide to do as a delayed site or was it
just to get your bridges in order and
your finance and get you get your plans
I think one of the biggest things that I
learned about doing a br uh painful
painful lesson um I've been Yorkshire
was the fact that planning just you know
wasn't the the most easiest and yeah it
takes forever the fact that I started on
a bridge without planning was a huge
cause of concern for for me in future
that's good it's a good lesson so yeah I
thought it was important to do it this
way no it's a good lesson so what are
you wanting what are you wanting um like
in terms of investment what are you sort
of pitching for and so at the moment a
hundred thousand's gone into the project
great where'd you get that from so it
was myself and also
um an investor
um put in we both split it for the
purchase
um so we're looking to whose name is it
going in your soul man this is 100 in my
name
um we are giving profit shares so we
aren't able to have too many investors
um we're only looking for two more
investors to invest in the project and
um they would they'll be getting profit
shares and how does that work the profit
so a profit share agreement it would
just be a profit share agreement
um and I would say we're given 10 for
every hundred thousand so if somebody
put in 360
000 then they would get 36 of the profit
of the project and 100 of the money out
so we're selling it in profit shares
what do you think bro yeah cool so let's
say you need 500 Grand right so someone
put the whole 500 Grand I know they
can't now because what would they get in
return half the profit half profit
okay yeah half off it exactly that so
you're making half the profit for
managing the deal doing everything
so yeah so you're making half of the
profit and then you're giving your
investors half of the profit divided
amongst them absolutely and you expect
the profit to be around about
yeah I would say about that so if you've
got 500 Grand in you'd get 150 Grand
back plus for 500 Grand yeah so you put
100 Grand in you'd get 10 in my mind
it's 10 isn't it so you'd get 100 like
let's say it's 300 000 you'd get 30 000
on top
yeah so it'll be 130 return on on your
investment okay which just learning from
you and what you've done I you know
understand it now and I feel that that
would be a good member is as an investor
if you're not doing anything yeah if
you're just investing into a project or
partnering into a project then you're
not going to make you're not going to
Triple your money because you just
invested
yeah so we've got um four big well a
small room there but four
um healthy size rooms downstairs a nice
bathroom and then we're gonna have a big
Master room with a master suite upstairs
or maybe a little a little office
um as well maybe that will be the little
office or something cool um for a family
there is HMO then
because obviously this is coming
conservation how many rooms would you
would you get because you need planning
if there's seven or more right yeah it
would change it would change but it
would change the whole layout because
downstairs would have to be rooms then
you'd have to add a living room you'd
leave them out the same wouldn't you
it's five rooms right now is that right
or six
two downstairs
like a grand maybe a month yeah so
you're gonna get five grand a month but
then on a million pound or 1.6 million
pound house this house in the area
looking at about seven thousand Pounds a
month rent yeah it's a family home and
as an airbn being you're looking at
about 650 a night wow that's
conservative all right cool let's head
down
so you got a viewing in like 20 minutes
next door or a few doors down just to
see what a donut version looks like
that's so smart and then you can see
what the darn and how they've developed
it
yeah
yeah a couple of good puns okay guys so
I've just shown around Samuel and
Russell around this property which I'm
so excited about
um obviously they're my mentors and
they've been supporting me throughout my
whole Journeys they've come and they've
seen the project but to be honest with
you they're outside having a bit of a
chat with my architect so the likelihood
that they're going to want to invest in
my deal is very very high trust me let's
see but you know it makes sense because
I love what I do you know I'm really
really proud of this project I'm really
proud of how I secured it how I
negotiated it the amount that we're
putting it in in the gdv
um so man I just feel like it's one of
those projects as soon as I purchase it
I've had people throw money at me you
know it's just one of those types of
projects where it's so seamless I've
already had people throw money at me so
the fact that they're out there having a
moment and a minute for me is just a
little solidifies what I've actually
brought to the tables you are a boss
I like it I like it think it's
cool building the best the best property
Ambassador in the UK number one boss
mofo you're amazing I think before
we invested we just need to run the
numbers on the refurb and obviously
check
check the figures oh it is the
thing right she
has to buy it
she's running ahead with this deal
didn't she yeah with or without us
so the question is
do we want to be part of it even even if
we don't invest the full 3A so even if
we invest a smaller amount like 100
grand
do we want to be part of this project do
we think that it could
be a big win do you think it's good do
you want you want to be involved I like
it I'd like to be involved
you don't want to put the foreman here
no maybe half or something maybe
something like that
yeah
but I like it my biggest fear especially
if we're not investing a massive amount
of money if we are invested I'm going to
get involved in the project and you know
help them with the planning she's got a
good team she's got the Architects she's
got all the building team but you are
going to get involved
to be more because you're going to want
to get five more but then aren't you
already mentoring
Trail anyway like as a student true
you're already involved in all of our
projects where you're not getting paid
at least get paid get paid for it that's
true that's true
that's true I like it though I think
it's good I think it's a good project so
what should we say to jail I think we
should not agree to put all the money in
but I think we should agree to invest
but right now yeah
let's go and tell her so
we like the project we like you if
you'll have us as an investor we would
love to partner with you on this project
are you joking
stop thank you
so much so yeah you guys are amazing and
I think I think as well I don't know
exactly how much you need but we were
thinking not to not put in all the money
but we'll definitely partner with you so
we'll have to have like I know you've
got a view in a second but we'll have a
follow-up conversation
um so yeah if you want to just get us
like the contracts and stuff sent over
perfect and all the surveys that you've
got yep that would be awesome amazing
thank you guys I hope you enjoyed this
video I kind of forgot that we've been
being filmed this whole time but if you
want to get involved in projects like
this then come down to the property
investors crash course you're the first
person to ever book on the crash course
what would you say about someone that's
thinking about coming to the property oh
my god seriously do it I became a
property millionaire in 11 months so
definitely do it also if you want to get
in touch with JL if you want to talk
about investing in projects with her
doing Partnerships with her she's
absolute Beast boss lady brilliant
property investor I'd recommend that how
come people get in touch with you JL
um you could just follow me on Instagram
DM me link in the description so I'll
see you around enjoy your viewing take
care
[Music]
thank you